but like they
just Relentless yeah they were
Relentless new video obtained by the
Ingram mangle reveals just how far
special counsel Jack Smith's team will
go in their investigation into Donald
Trump body cam video warned by officers
called to the home of a Georgia Trump
codefendant shows the aftermath of his
encounter with FBI agents there to
reportedly serve a grand jury subpoena
former black voices for Trump director
Harrison Floyd says he was going home
with his daughter when men wearing suits
looking like they quote popped out of
the show Better Call Saul started
running at him I start yelling at one of
them like who do you think you are
you're you're haven't seen any bags you
haven't told me anything I don't know
who you are grabbing grabbing and
touching me then one of them who's on
the stairs has a he goes like this and
he has a pistol in his hand I never saw
a badge yeah I saw gun though Flo was
then arrested and charged with
assaulting one of those agents and
joining me now is his attorney Chris
kerov Chris thanks for being with us
your client's accused of body slamming
one of those agents knocking him
backwards with his body that's the
allegation what can you tell
us if you read the police report I mean
that that's something that came out of
the I think wo published that I don't
know where they got it from they should
have retracted that but at the end of
the day if you look at the police report
it's odd odd to say leas because
remember these are two FBI agents
they're law enforcement and if you look
at the state police report remember
Harrison called the police when these
strange people came up to his house and
followed him when you look at the state
police report U he is the one who called
and he's the victim He's listed as the
victim and then 10 hours later they show
up back at his door to arrest him well
if you look at the police report and you
see what these FBI agents have said I
don't know I used to be a former police
officer and I can tell you right now if
you touch a police officer in his nose
you get that close to him where you're
you're you're pointing at his nose and
you're literally touching his nose
poking his cheek as they said in the
police report spitting on him and
cursing you're G to get hooked I don't
know a police officer who wouldn't poke
you now they can say well he's an MMA
former MMA martial artist I would have
uh you know I we wanted to deescalate
that's not what happens you you touch an
officer and he's identified himself and
he's shown you his badge of authority
that's it case over you're getting
hooked so I don't buy what they said
yeah and your your client is saying and
we can see it in that video that those
officers did not identify themselves
when they approached uh Harrison Floy
that's right that's right yeah I mean
that's what you're supposed to do
especially if you're in you're in a suit
in a plain clothes suit your job is as
an officer is you walk up and you say
listen I'm an officer with such and such
a department and you have to have your
badge and gun out that's why you see
detectives even on shows where wearing
badges around their neck yeah and I want
to clarify for the audience the video
that we're seeing on our screen is that
second visit you referenced these are
the police officers showing up after
Floyd calls the police officers the
original encounter with the FBI agent
serving The subpoena we do not have on
on video and thus we have these these
conflicting testimonies but let's take
one more look let's let's take a look at
this video with the uh with the officers
that Floyd called to show up at his
door if they are who they say they are I
want to know who the supervisor is and I
want to press charges against whoever
those two are who are coming after me
with my daughter pulling me on stairs if
you serve people a subpoena that's not
the way it's done I agree with you so so
to be clear those officers he he alleges
did not identify themselves as officers
of the law he calls the cops which are
now seeing on video right there and what
happens Chris he ends up being arrested
for the alleged assault in the first
encounter right because and that's the
odd thing is they had the state police
arrest him for a state crime and then
just shortly before I mean that was 10
hours after he made the report so you
can imagine his surprise that he now
gets arrested um and then knowing how
embarrassing it must look to the FBI to
have the state police make the arrest uh
shortly before the court case in
Maryland in the state level we got a
phone call to say they're they're
dismissing that case and they're going
to indict him federally and so he's got
misdemeanor charges pended right now at
the uh Federal level and I've heard that
they want to now upgrade it to a felony
so I it's crazy to me I mean like I said
no police officer worth his salt even
even an FBI agent is going to uh uh do
this type of of shenanigan I call it a
shenanigan it's very suspicious that
they didn't make the report themselves
all right Chris we really appreciate you
being with us tonight sharing this story
and that video with our audience thank
you hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else